okay so the first thing I'm going to
notice is see how I went from this graph
to the first derivative and I looked at
gradients okay I looked at great this
tells me about the grading of this well
in exactly the same way if I took out
this guy if I took out the first graph
and just started with this I repeat the
same exercise right this raft tells me
about the gradient of this okay I'm not
going to draw it on because I'm too
literally going to avoid it because
it'll become confusing but you can see
look at the side negative negative
negative negative negative negative
that's the gradient it's decreasing do
you see that zero positive positive
positive positive which is exactly the
regions that this is passing through
does that make sense
sign of the gradient here gives me
regions that I passed through here but
and here's the real kicker right I'm
interesting about the second derivative
like it's a first derivative of this
first derivative but I really want to
know what this tells me about this okay
now think about this right remember we
said okay look at this point in here at
this interval in here right the graph is
decreasing
you notice that and that corresponds to
the fan fits down here the festivities
is negative okay but it's not the same
negative then the type of negative does
change right I don't know about the
values but I know for instance that down
here this is the most negative the
derivative gets right you see that
that's the lowest it goes it's the
minimum now geometrically what does that
mean up here that means now I'm going to
get to that word in a second but just
more basically right if it's more
negative that means it's steeper because
that's what grading is about right are
you steep a shallow right more negative
means mostly in the negative direction
now therefore at that point that's the
most negative and as I move away from
that point I get less and less negative
until I get 0 and I get less and less
negative my twenties you're here okay
think about it another way right do you
notice as I'm going from left to right
left to right okay again starting at
this stationary point on 0 here and I'm
in the negative direction think of like
a lift right in the negative direction
I'm speeding up I'm starting to drop off
faster until I get to this point and
then what happens I start to slow down
right remember we're talking about like
things going up there going down are
they getting faster or are they getting
slowed up okay so from here to here the
behavior even though the gradient is
still negative so it's still decreasing
but it's a different kind of decreasing
right from here to here I'm speeding up
from here I'm slowing down does that
make sense yeah okay I will get to that
I won't get to find out that corner in a
second okay the important thing I want
you get in on I'm I'm drastic you're
putting on clothes I've used before in
my color so I'm just going to repurpose
my Ritalin okay I want us to notice the
sign of this thing and how corresponds
to what we were just describing over
here okay do you ever I said okay from
here to here that's from one two okay is
it getting faster or getting slower it's
getting faster right it's getting faster
now what does that correspond to here
right getting faster and it's decreasing
so it's negative have a look it it
crystals to this getting dropping and
dropping and dropping and doing to the
lowest point it gets to a lowest point
and then it stops right and then instead
of getting faster it's getting so on
okay do you see that which corresponds
to this first derivative getting zero
okay it's still negative
now this point where you transition
right from this kind of behavior to this
kind of behavior is to x equals two that
guy right there
okay now this idea of getting fast
against law do you see it's not just
happening on the inside do you notice
that oh can you see it's happening on
the outsides as well for example how
would you just
this is Pacquiao I'm slowing down I'm
really really positive here right which
of course wants this being really really
positive really increasing very steep
and then it slows down okay yeah it
speeds up okay so what's this talking
about this getting faster getting slower
business okay here my was this graph it
tells you about where I am so this is a
word that I would use to describe that
where are you it's positioned right a
fancy word that you might use this
displacement okay but that's that's
where are you where are you
this guy here tells me about gradients
right how much is your position changing
as you change your x-values in a
physical context we would use the word
speed and that's why we're saying
getting faster getting slower now what
you're getting now if you have a look to
the left of deer and to the right of
here okay I want you to get a piece of
paper and I want you to cover up half of
this graph over here also the right-hand
side so we can only see the left-hand
side more someone's plain piece of paper
okay
okay I'm going to cover the UM the
right-hand side here okay I want you to
look at everything to the left of this
special point right the special point
where things the behavior changes okay
everything to the left of this I've got
a negative second derivative do you
notice that negative secondly what that
corresponds to is the shape of this
graph if you imagine a bit like a cup
okay
it's a cup that's facing down do you see
that which way is this seam facing up or
down like a parabola
okay whereas if I move now can I cover
up this side it's still that kind of you
know curved shape it's like a cuff but
it's not facing out anymore it's facing
up that corresponds to this sign down
here being up okay now which way is this
facing in
in lenses we talk about concave and
convex lenses right which way is the
lens facing I've actually got boys
because on the long side and
short-sighted okay
this it doesn't have two sides the lens
right
it's either facing down or its facing up
the word we use rather than position by
gradient is what we call concavity we
take that word kwan cave right and that
refers to which ways the cut busy okay
in this part of the graph its facing
down right which corresponds to the fact
that down here the second derivative is
negative this paragraph is facing down
over here to the right the second ribbon
is positive which corresponds to the
fact that our original graph is concave
up okay now remember I made a big deal
about the fact that this spot is where
things change this spot is where things
that I hate differently okay
we call that spot where it changes it's
not a stationary point it's not that
I've stopped moving actually that's the
fastest that I'm moving in a negative
direction okay when we call that point
is a point of inflection okay it flexes
from facing downwards to facing upwards
okay so we have 10 points here in here
and this guy is pretty proud isn't it is
a point of inflection now you will see
frequently that this is abbreviated
petered by I never appreciated PR i--'s
because what of an affliction is is just
to say the point of intersection which
is actually something that you will
frequently be finding so I never write
that
yes exactly now this is what we're
looking at when we talk about different
kinds of stationary points right we
looked at on maxima minima and then I
said this these guys right and I said
it's a little bit awkward that I have to
give you their name
and their name didn't mean anything well
now it does because have a look at how
these things change okay
the gestation points here at here okay
tell me now now that you have a category
and organism
tell me about the king cavity of these
two stationary birds to stay the same
they stay the same right now my maximum
is concave down you see that all the way
through it's concave down my minimum is
concave up all the way through but have
a look at these two guys down here they
are both also station reports but the
concavity is changed right on the left
hand side for this guy okay concave you
like I think you better see that for
then as you transition past that
horizontal point of inflection it's
concave up and of course it's in Reverse
for this guy well yeah we talked about a
function it's pursue and its second
derivative right the sign of these first
objective second derivatives they tell
you about this one are you going up
where you going down this one
aiyoo concave up or concave down okay
that's what the signs tell you them what
did the zeros tell you about here
the zeros tell you about intercepts here
the zeros tell you about stationary
points here the zeros tell you about
time now I'm gonna say points of
inflection and I'm going to put an
asterisk there okay as we're going to
look at next week and you actually
already have the tools at your disposal
to know number one you can have a point
of inflection where that's the secondary
being 0 that's the first thing I'm going
to say in fact I've already giving these
table I will point out to you again if
you can't remember it okay but the first
thing is you can have a point of
inflection without the second derivative
be 0 but even more read you can have the
secondary of being 0 and not have a
point of inflection
ok they are not unlike here where it's
like if you've got a gradient of 0 then
that means
stationary point and if you've got a
stationary point that means you've got a
great into zero right so these are like
they mutually well yeah they they they I
get I can deduce one from the other
okay if the concavity if the second
derivative equals zero do I get a point
of inflection
well maybe question mark there actually
I have to go into the internet ookay
right and if I have a point of
inflection does that mean that the
second derivative is zero and the answer
is well maybe right and I will show you
the special cases where sometimes it's
the other way around
okay but this is generally the case
generally meaning usually usually that's
what happens okay does anyone any
questions before I get you start on the
first time yes okay so have a look here
have a look here at this point what's
happening to my arm first really our
first derivative is negative its
decreasing that's why it's going down
I've got my green negative sign right
but that point is where the second
derivative is zero and that's why I have
a point of inflection right the coup
cavity went from concave down to concave
up and so that's what makes it a point
of inflection okay so it doesn't mean
that the gradient is zero the gradient
is non zero the second derivative is
zero okay